if you even for a second think it's a
good idea for Apple and Google and
Facebook to help you be less addicted
you are on the path of losing you don't
like Instagram delete the second we
allow ourselves to let the machines help
ourselves is the second you become more
vulnerable I believe that you want Apple
to limit the amount of time you're on
Instagram for you like you think that's
what you if you want that Mazel Tov take
it but like I promise you then there's
going to be the next thing and the next
thing and the next thing social media is
exposing us it's not changing us there
is no social media brother they're empty
pipes social media doesn't make you mean
social media doesn't make you insecure
you're insecure you're me we're getting
exposed not changed we're addicted to
human interaction the reason the world
exists in a world where we've had atomic
bombs for 70 years is we like each other
we're not addicted to social media we
are interactive preachers you're
addicted to people cool you don't want
to be on Instagram go read vote knock
yourself out this is a very fun thing
for me to watch about people don't like
being held accountable need motivation
watch a top 10 with believe Nation hey
it's Evan Karma and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the
Gary vaynerchuk and my take on his top
10 rules to success
a lot of things the way that these
platforms claim they're addictive is the
way a lot of things are addictive
are we going to ban pretty people
are we going to limit our time to
watching comedy
are we going to limit the time we listen
to music
this is a really this is the
demonization bless you this is the
demonization of Technology let me give
you a really good piece of advice go
read the articles around the
kaleidoscope
I'm being dead serious go Google the
early articles around the kaleidoscope
you'll think you're reading about
Instagram
history's got all the answers
I failed I could not be in this program
because I failed all my classes but
the one class I was good at was history
and it is the continuous framework of
how I think about a lot of this stuff
literally the articles of the
Kaleidoscope are making the same
arguments now
so
if you have fomo
it's because you have levels of
insecurity that are raging which has a
lot more to do with the way you were
parented and where you grew up and the
natural DNA you were given
not
Snapchat
so how do I think it's going to play out
in its worst our government gets
disproportionately involved which will
be fine
I could care less just so everybody
knows I care about attention not social
media
so if we all stop doing social media I'm
going to figure out where your eyes and
ears are going you're going to go
somewhere
we're not locking ourselves up in a room
so I don't give a [ __ ] Google and
Facebook and Twitter and Instagram and
Snapchat and Tick Tock and Linkedin can
disappear off the face of the Earth
tomorrow and I'd probably be the single
happiest person because my most
comfortable state is reacting quickly to
where attention goes
um
I just feel bad for any human being that
thinks that's going to help them
because they're going to find something
else to complain about
or to be controlled by this is an
internal framework conversation not an
external technology conversation rule
number two be obsessed I'm really in
rarified air of like deep obsession with
my process and enjoyment and lack of
anxiety from it and lack of burnout from
it I think I hit my Crescendo I think
I'm more of an artist
I don't think people realize that
business women and men are actually
there's a certain version of us that are
artists that genuinely like this more
than anything
like like we like singing like Beyonce's
workaholic yeah you know like Kobe was a
workaholic absolutely over their craft
there are four of their expressions yeah
so for me like like we demonize it in in
entrepreneurship and corporate life but
we don't in art
we put artists we put oh he's in the
studio all the time wow you know
painting all the time wow cooking and
traveling the world to buy food wow
business oh he's gonna burn out he's
gonna suicidal what is that is it just
because of the old way of thinking like
getting burned out in the corporate
world of doing the job you hate and yeah
money money you know I don't think
people like Mark texiera made 213
million dollars playing baseball but if
some entrepreneur makes 30 million they
get demonized it's just culture it's
just culture and it's okay like I don't
I don't think that's wrong right or
indifferent it's just the obvious
observation right we demonize the
startup founder or the businesswoman
much much more than the Entertainer that
makes way more money rule number three
worry about your own actions what you
need to do if you have this mission
accomplished is worry about your actions
not anybody else's
the biggest problem in our society right
now is everybody worries about
everybody's actions but their own
on every side of the equation
so what I would tell you to do is what
I'm doing for a living which is I have
all I have unbelievable
social wants of kindness for the world
but I'm not going to allow my friends to
tell me how to do that
my friends tell me I need to be a
keyboard Warrior on Twitter I think
they're foolish and trying to look good
on social media but don't live their
truth
so it's about understanding the unique
perspective that you bring and not
letting other people kind of like play
with that
in action meaning
continue to do your podcast
continue to put out content continue to
work wear your T-shirt but not worry
about what anybody else is doing with it
because when you try to boil the ocean
you don't rule number four be fear proof
what's been your biggest fear in all of
this or do you feel like you're pretty
fear proof at this moment with
everything you've been through I'm fear
proof because I'm willing to go to zero
yeah you can live on a small apartment
and you know live in your parents house
it really can man yeah I don't know what
else to say like this has proven it to
me even more you know any point zero
zero zero one percent of me that thought
well I've been saying this for the last
two years am I foolish has completely
gone away
yeah like I just I don't fear because I
don't value things and money
I my biggest fear is my parents getting
sick
like my biggest fear is like somebody
getting sick and dying nothing else like
business I can always like I'm too
capable right like you know back to back
to the thing you brought up back to why
you were an Olympian back to like why
you beat me everything that anything
when we were on Summit scene whatever
basketball like you aren't worried
when it comes to sport you know your
mind just goes into this is going to be
a good situation for me yeah yeah and I
feel comfortable yeah and for me that's
business like I know for a fact that if
I became a 100 full-time garage sale
thrift store Amazon flipper did I make a
million dollars a year I I know that for
a fact so what the hell am I and that
doesn't take into account that I am that
I've built a brand and sure my brand
would take a hit if I all my businesses
went to zero but the reality is
America's funny man like there's people
following and helping O.J Simpson
there's you know Wolf of Wall Street
like like this is a country that gives
second third four chances regardless
and so like I'm already at a place right
now where between brand and capability
and humility
I'm bulletproof also if you want to have
Unstoppable confident self-love and
motivation check out my 254 series
they're free the link to join are in the
description below we are strong
we're really strong we're just being
sold that we're not because there's a
lot of money you need to put your
earpods in and listen to positivity 24
7. do you understand when your
surroundings are your insides got to be
positive the biggest obstacle uh to
success is a lack of optimism rule
number five focus on the end result the
reality is I know what's going on in the
Vayner World obviously I know what's
going on uh in the broad sense but I
spent almost no time
auditing what other brands are doing and
plus if we're talking from a brand
standpoint well has to be reflected in
business results there's a ton of people
that are going to win awards today that
business is declining dramatically and I
struggle with that because the point of
that creativity is to drive a business
result in this context or get people to
vote or inspire a movement or cure a
disease like what's the point of output
if you're not getting the end result
rule number six live your truth I think
the reason my voice is resonating is I'm
not affected by anybody else right now
I'm only affected by the way people are
reacting to me which allows me to
continue to build in the purity of human
truths without blending and trying to be
like
so you're clearly a very busy guy with
controlling your Public Image and you'll
appreciate this real quick on that front
just to jump in I'll let you finish I
give zero thoughts to controlling my
Public Image zero
I mean they doc my team's in here I
don't even look at what they're making
the way I control my Public Image is by
living my truth and letting the chips
fall
it's the most liberating thing of all
time I don't think about it at all rule
number seven have a balance I do think
my parents for me and they parented all
three kids a little bit differently but
like but they're like we really they
were such Workaholics both my mom my mom
was a stay-at-home mom but like did
everything like you know like like you
know and I think people very much
underestimate stay-at-home moms as
Workaholics like she just worked her
face off no help no breaks no breaks we
were all
spoiled kids from the back of laundry
and doing our bed and she cooked
everything and like and then my dad came
home late because and cooked right like
she worked her face off so they could
have created a little more balance we
only took two family vacations so they
taught me work out the kindness
everything everything I am was them but
but I do think the thing that we have
more is balance with you know Leisure
and and offsetting 24 7 work but they
that makes sense it's generational they
came here with nothing and it was 24 7
work and I have so much that that in me
but I've had the luxury of my talents
leading to a success that's allowed me
to post you know listen that's how my
first 10 years professionally looked too
but now being able to take a little bit
of time and so maybe a little balance
because I think they regret that and and
so you try to take your parents regrets
and not have the same and so I look at
that rule number eight create Clarity I
care about people's emotions and
happiness and and overall livelihood not
what they produce for me me in the short
term as an employee of my company I
don't know what else to say I care more
about I look at our voluntary retention
numbers
10 times more than I look at our profit
margin
and I'm I'm an HR driven CEO not a CFO
driven Co here's why I want to create
Clarity for everybody who's listening
because I'm playing forever
I own my businesses I'm so for me I can
do things that lead to retention and a
real relationship because I'm not held
accountable to Wall Street or a public
market or a board or I'm so money hungry
that I want a yacht and I believe most
are rule number nine be thoughtful what
is amazing about the volume model
is the notion of marketing for the sake
of better marketing
so what happens after you post those 78
is you start getting Quant and qual
feedback
and what you do with that feedback is
you make the next decision which is are
you going to write more about that or
has there been such a huge reaction
to people's response on what 5G actually
means to their day-to-day not just
faster and better battery but how our
entire world changes when you create
that speed of information how that
actually makes autonomous cars real how
that actually allows a doctor in Peru to
perform a surgery on somebody in New
York how that actually actually does
when you see the response now all of a
sudden you say you know what that little
three sentences we said about did you
know when 5G is in your life this
happens got such a big response why
don't we now have our
graphic designer make an infographic
real quick around five things you don't
know about 5G and let's post that at 3
37 p.m today
and then when that goes well then you
decide why don't make a quick little
video on our iPhone talking to Lars in r
d he knows a lot about this
let's go over to him Lord says and then
you just post it not with what's quality
with green screen and lighting I mean I
was powdered before I came out here
right now
that to me is not the variable of
success of this talk
it was not going to be the variable that
made this go well or not
was what I was going to say and Lars
with an iPhone with bad lighting saying
something thoughtful and then that
posted at 704 p.m on our Twitter to the
small group that cares matters and so
when you get into that mindset you can
see how it works and it's really just
having writers
designers something we call Predators
shredditors which are people who can
film and post-produce for the Channel
all in one person
humans
commitment to being able to pay those
people to do the thing
because you value that more than
the lighting in your booth
in Spain at a conference and Rule Number
10 the last one before a very special
bonus clip is test and learn a single
thing I'm most proud of sitting at can
is there's not a human here not one that
makes more creative output than I do on
a daily basis and Collective period that
is an audacious but factual statement
there's not one person here that makes
more content than I do and I'm a CEO of
a company not a creative and in that you
can imagine in a world where me and my
team are producing 40 to 100 pieces of
content a day across all these platforms
there's a practitionership that allows
me I mean the amount of mistakes
you know it's fun to have drock here
because he's on the text chain with me
and my team we changed our mind seven
times a month
I constantly [ __ ] on my own self once a
week like I emphatically on Monday say
it's all about this and literally next
Tuesday go if we ever do that again
we're I mean this is real life this is
the truth and you're testing and
learning with yourselves at a scale that
is unseen right now and should be
replicated by everyone which gives me
much better insights to what the
consumer's reacting to and then
obviously I'm a human with a certain
kind of flavor so that doesn't map to
Dove the same exact way so there's macro
things we see that we deploy and then we
see how it plays out it's never literal
for me to I'm a human I'm a 43 year old
man there's a lot of things that don't
navigate but there's a lot of the truths
that we navigate that we test and learn
there and that we scale so it is the
ultimate test lab
how much time do you spend on marketing
he said those four things how much time
do you actually spend on it in a day
Zero sometimes I assume yeah sometimes
in a week how much do you spend on it
two hours great now is the most
important part of this meeting
how many hours do you sleep at night
great so I love the way you said it I
have to have seven so if I wanted to say
go to six so that you pick up five
you're gonna say to me Gary I have to
have seven right
now let's go somewhere else I have to
know what you're doing the other 17
hours I would bet the house
that we can find an hour every day I
guarantee you because you might be
working all 17 hours but you might not
be working on something smarter than
spending an hour a day on the thing that
you're talking about
do you understand yeah yeah that's
that's the answer
the answer is time you know people talk
about working hard and working smart the
answer is only both
you have to work hard and smart based on
your ambition if you want to build a
business for yourself that is like a one
percent life most people understand what
building a business for yourself is it's
very special yeah it's very special
trying to build a business for yourself
everybody's doing now pulling it off
trying to play basketball everybody can
try being an NBA player trying to be a
rapper or a singer everybody's doing
pulling it off trying to be a footballer
an actress got it so you're trying great
pulling it off is hard it takes
everything time and smarts you need
seven I'm glad you said it that way
because this makes this piece of content
more valuable it's the 17 other hours
I'll give you an example A lot of people
drive to work for 45 minutes if they
took a bus for an hour and 15 minutes
they would save money and get more work
done
but do you have the humility to take the
bus versus driving your car it is far
more fun to die on your sword than to
die on someone else's I'm inspired
YouTube we're gonna make this the
episode thing you'll get whatever you
want Tyler but this is the core but you
just saw it on stage I'm sorry you just
saw it on stage
dying on your sword is better than dying
on someone else's so many of you are
doing things making decisions and
navigating your lives based on somebody
else's thesis you're doing it because
you think it's the right thing because
your dad's telling you it's the right
thing you're doing what you're doing
right now because you're pandering to
your boss even though you don't believe
in it this is how it's going to play out
you are doing things right now yesterday
you made a decision that you don't
believe in or you're smart you did it
because you know how your company scores
here's the problem with disruption and
Innovation right now you're being
rewarded for being a yes person
and in 36 months you're going to be
fired for being a yes person and you're
doing it because you just need the
security of your job I'm telling you
right now if you're watching this Vlog
and you've got like that means you have
a certain DNA please I implore you
please die on your sword not somebody
else's If You're Gonna Lose it's much
more fun to lose based on what you
thought do you know I mean do you know
how many of you are gonna lose on
somebody else's thesis it's gonna kill
at you it's going to eat at you it's
going to be the worst feeling so please
pause this video right now and ask
yourself am I doing my [ __ ] because of
me then you're good whether you're
winning or losing or am I doing it
because somebody else is telling me it's
the right way or I'm subconsciously
pandering to please somebody or
something because I need the short-term
stability figure that out you know it
and I know
I know you just need to do something
about it the way I do branding I sell so
infrequently uh that I think some of you
that are watching me the hardest core
need to hear this which is it's okay to
sell especially if you believe in
something like if you believe in what
you're selling and that's what I'm
spending a lot of time on now trying to
spend more time on really getting to a
place where I really believe in stuff
instead of just passive not creating so
I wasn't selling because I didn't
believe you know and just letting
everything come to me but as I create
these you know events Vayner experience
a lot of events very big on events
events are so valuable just watching the
4ds crew it's value and like how it's
impacting their business for ten
thousand dollars right there I mean you
see I know you're getting emails
um the wine club like 150 worth of wine
for 55 bucks like I'm just locked in
November's it's gonna make all your
thanksgivings ridiculous the conference
500 two hour session in my stomping
grounds good deal compared to like other
conferences that I speak at
um
but you're getting the wine for free or
you're getting the top for free and
you're getting the wine so like I'm very
fascinated because I'm putting more
pressure on myself to create things that
I really believe in
which then allows me to sell more and I
just think for a lot of you selling the
ask the right hook is very difficult uh
your your passive you like the idea of
like feeling good about like giving out
content this and that when you believe
in something
you can sell it and and you should put
more pressure on yourself to create
things that you believe in biggest
problem is so many of you sell you don't
believe in you're just doing it for the
money you're gonna lose
that I don't like I think when I get the
praise it's what the [ __ ] does that have
to do with me when I get done I'm like
that's on me and I'll fix it and I think
those you know that was just I said it
really quick but it's an accountability
it's accountability and ownership when
you suck and it's passing on the credit
and that's it
it's me and have my makeup
and that's why I'm winning in life and
that's why I'm always going to win
because when you are a hundred percent
accountable
and know your your garbage when you're
100 countable when there's an issue
and when you pass on the praise when
you're getting it
fundamentally under
unbeatable I'm straight up unbeatable
because my head will never get gassed up
enough ever when I'm getting it good and
uh
and I'll never believe it's me and when
it's bad I'll never point the finger to
anybody else all you finger pointers
pointing everywhere everybody's pointing
fingers pointing them everywhere it's
everybody's problem yourself the country
your environment your parents school
system your boss your aunt
circumstances are the force and of
course there's tragedies and crimes and
child abuse and real bad stuff I'm not
saying it's not real I'm saying for the
95 of you it's a mindset thing
perspective
perspective is everything
grounded in my perspective
High number too low
it's about them when it's good it's
about
it's about me
that's what I got for you that's where
I'm at that's what my mindset and I
never waver
100 never had my bad days
what today's raw Batman here is uh all
bent out of shape he just said uh today
is rough to be very Frank with you
Vayner Nation I don't give a [ __ ] if
Tyler or you think today was rough
because I had 17 meetings that he
couldn't be a part of because I'm
actually running a business here I'm not
from some teenage beanie bopper trying
to do a vlog or some influencer doing a
blog or some family that's hoping for
some free detergent because of their
blog I'm working here to Tyler so sorry
that your video blog is rough but let me
tell you what's not rough what's not
rough is we're living through the Great
era of ground shift in marketing and
business everybody in this amazing town
of New York City which is let me just
tell you everybody who's not here
vibrant at 10 at PM right now because 98
of your cities are sleeping
everybody here is their Collective pants
because the ground is Shifting
everything that our grandparents and
parents grew up with everything that we
knew tried and true the stable pillars
of media Commerce uh influence
persuasion the way we make decisions the
things we buy and how what is cool and
what is not is on call
the world is on call
and you know what that means Hustlers
the opportunity is obnoxious so whether
you're focusing on vlogs
or influencers or how to hack Instagram
stories or how to create Alexa voice
skills or how to create your own podcast
because you see I'm full committed tilt
if you are not following my podcast
pissed
the way I call today the the sum up of
all my meetings today none of which you
just watched is that the Earth is moving
there's instability in the foundation of
how it was which makes an innovator like
me really happy and what suffocates all
you be players because you like it you
like it nice slow and stable let it be
very clear with this ending rant that
game is over the people that are going
to win over the next five to seven years
are going to be very comfortable in
Controlled Chaos so you better get your
speed up you better work harder you
better work smarter you better try
things you better keep your
subjectiveness and your ego at the door
because that slows you down and it
doesn't make you do you better move I
know that if I can suffocate all of you
today to take 25 percent of your
take-home income this year and pour it
back into two people who do video and
written word
and put it into Facebook and Instagram
ads literally all of you will email me
24 months actually [ __ ] it if you can
start right away literally
25 percent of you are going to come to
me this time next year right here and be
like holy [ __ ] I've been listening to
your stuff for seven years
your keynote was different in Miami last
year this time I listened I said [ __ ] it
I don't need to go to Ibiza three times
this year [ __ ] it I don't need to buy a
better BMW this year to make me feel
good with the neighbors [ __ ] it I don't
need another pair of Supremes or Yeezys
I took the money and I put it into Karen
the film woman and Rick the ad guy
and now my business is 2x this will 100
work even if you suck
on camera have Zero Charisma
are only eight days in the industry this
will work
because it is such underpriced attention
that the ROI will work that if you're a
two
in skill the ads are a 20 in the 10
point scale and it closes the Delta of
you being average if you literally
literally and I've said this for seven
years if you literally literally go
interview the guy who owns the gym in
town the guy who owns the pizza shop the
woman that owns the insurance brokerage
if you literally literally literally
just interview your local community that
you become the local newspaper in
three-minute video form on your phone
you don't even need to hire drock or bab
in your eyes your phone if you literally
take it selfie it and interview the
principal of the school in your
neighborhood you will become the local
celebrity who can then transact on
whatever you're trying to sell that
group if you bring value to people if
you interview the best high school
basketball player literally just that
your business will change or
if you literally just give the advice of
how you got here what you learned if you
shared your thoughts if you do not
understand that you were a media company
that you will not be as successful as
you are today in a decade
and that's not interesting when the
alternative is your four to seven times
bigger the state guys you have to
understand what happened to Blockbuster
and Netflix what happened with Uber and
taxi cut companies what happened with
hotels versus Airbnb is happening with
you as a human in your business
and so when you have the best hand and
you know it because you've been paying
attention and you know how to play poker
you go all in
everybody here is playing Facebook
Instagram social media YouTube
podcasting like they have the best hand
and they're calling
and you're not goading them into getting
all the money you're just folding and
that's this audience so can you imagine
what I feel is going on outside this
Stadium
so this is a call to action for
everybody to do me one favor and I do
think I can get a lot of you to do it
which excites the [ __ ] out of me
please right now listen maybe you've
laid out money maybe you're in the
middle of a renovation maybe you're
paying for your kids college Mazel Tov I
know there's nuances on everybody's life
but if you were in a position where
literally your take-home income this
year is literally the stuff you're gonna
go and do things with
please from 25 to 90 if you can go
humble please take that money and hire
two people to make a lot more content
for you about you and your business
and please give the rest of the money to
Facebook and YouTube and Instagram and I
fundamentally promise you you will walk
here to this conference next year and
personally thank me emotionally because
your business will change and I know not
one of you has gone all in two things
here
on Instagram and I'd like a Facebook
page for PRN Roofing my question bro
hold on
did you really think that was a good
idea
no bro I honestly think that that was
one of like the worst moves I've ever
seen because
[Applause]
and I and I'm not trying to razz you I
appreci I am talking I'm trying to give
you love I love the passion to win the
problem is you tried to close on the
first move
you brought them no value and you asked
them to bring you value
like you gave like I will stand up here
and give a [ __ ] load of value and never
mention one time for any of them to
follow me and a lot more of them will
follow me then I'm gonna follow that
[ __ ] move that you just did
I get it I get it but this was back to
the question that just happened this is
why I want you to win that move is
always going to lose you can't go
tonight when you go out in Vegas and you
see a pretty girl at the bar you can't
go up to her and the opening move is
like here's my key let's go thank you
but but that's what you just did let
them hold it but that's what you just
did to this audience with business
because
because so why why are you succeeding
and giving all your secrets away at the
same time
I mean because doing the right thing is
the right thing karma is practical
[Applause]
you know I heard somebody rant earlier
right that's like hey when I win I don't
think it's coming out of you the guy
that closed I couldn't know who was on
stage but I believe in that right
because I love the idea of 85 people
here going and listening to me winning I
didn't make anything for it but it then
becomes brand if she goes out and
listens and then two years later she's
having dinner with a friend and she's
talking about what happened to her life
that friend might be the CEO of GE you
know I'm playing with the biggest brands
in the world I'm not trying to monetize
my audience I'm trying to like just
bring the most value in the world and
let that lift all my other opportunities
so I think I think giving away your best
Secrets is the greatest strategy for two
reasons karma is practical and leads to
more business but here's the secret and
it's even funnier 99 of these people are
not going to do anything about it
the re somewhere about five or six years
ago I realized this fact holy [ __ ]
people aren't going to do anything with
this
so like there's still gonna be plenty
for me and I'm gonna be the most lovable
guy ever I love this so
you know today so this 50 of all the
money that I have people are dishing me
because they don't want to go to the
conference anymore so I've been just
full-on pissed right getting [ __ ] on
today yeah that sounds awesome well
today yeah I like it I like it and so I
like it I'll tell you why because I even
I can tell by your demeanor that you're
gonna be okay the fact that you realize
that that negative moment has positive
impact the question is why did it happen
and that's why you have to be honest
with yourself
I don't know you know but that's you
know I'm pumped that you can have the I
mean you're more positive and half the
people here and it sounds like you're
having a terrible day
so I wanted to ask you how do you keep
the positivity in the columnist when
everything is because basically when
things happen I go the other way
so tonight
I just was reminding myself every time I
every time you came and the next person
came I was just reminding my literally
in my own head saying you don't mean I
said it to one of you I said they said
how do you stay humble whenever you're
so successful I'm like because I know if
I die tomorrow I'll have a good day on
social media
be like oh that was the last one weird
and and I know that all of you will be
on with your life a week later
you have to balance your ego with
humility in the same way when I'm having
my worst day I realize I'm the best
I'm gonna be the best that ever does
this
and so the way I handle things is when
something's going one way I use all my
emotional strength to push the other way
what are you gonna cry for the rest of
your life because the conference got
[ __ ] up
like I just like to me it's just like
look what the [ __ ] guys if you're in
this room right now let me just remind
you that there are 7.7 billion people
literally right now as we stand here
there are women being shipped to be
strippers
in parts of our world right now as we
stand here there are women who are
basically caged mentally usually and are
being shipped to dance on a pole in
Manhattan and in London like do you
understand what's there's there's
genocide going on right now like what do
you think is going on
like we lack perspective your conference
got [ __ ] up boohoo I lost a client
boohoo there's people dying out there
like like so when Americans or Europeans
talk to me about race or gender I'm sad
it's the real life but I remind them
because it's a positive thing cool but
let me tell you about the person that's
ranked 7 billion in the world
they have it
have it and so I just I struggle like I
want to like I listen I'm weird I think
about things like animals like I don't
know like if you're the best elephant we
are still better than you
you know like
like listen you know I got hot on this
about a year ago the 400 trillion to one
it's impossible to be a human being you
won
I don't know how to get upset after that
I keep [ __ ] in perspective right like
you're going to learn from this you
[ __ ] up
I promise you it's failing because of
you
and and when you start owning your and
not blaming other people and I think
this is the kick I've been on lately on
Instagram right like blame yourself you
know why I'm always happy I believe
myself
when you blame yourself for real you're
gonna always be happy
because you don't feel like somebody
else controls you I'm 26.
um I want to be uh I I want to say a
marriage counselor but every time I
mention that like go you know uh what do
you want to do with your life and I tell
people this
um their instant response is you know
how you're going to do that you're not
married
um
my parents are divorced as if I was
eight since I was eight
um I'm not married I can I can answer
your question right away we're going to
build an amazing yeah we're going to
build an amazing case study together I'm
going to give you I'm going to give you
three names
um and then you're gonna cruise into the
sunset of success which is let's figure
out the three most successful coaches in
the history of sport that everybody
knows of that didn't play that sport
Bill Belichick even though I hate him
with all my guts did not play football
he grew up in the football game right
his dad and what was a coach wouldn't
have you but Bill Belichick did not play
football and he will probably
unfortunately go down as the greatest or
if not one of the greatest head coaches
of all time you don't have to be listen
I think you have to be people have to be
thoughtful I hate 22 year old life
coaches that haven't lived life but if
they if they speak about here's my life
experiences and and why you can
eliminate though very quickly the art
when somebody says to you but how are
you gonna you can't do let me first of
all a couple other questions are your
friends and your circle telling you you
can't do that or are customers that
you're trying to do that with telling
you that they don't want to go with you
because you're not married
uh no this this is more acquaintances uh
people you know that I run into yeah so
listen that's something listen that's a
mistake
like you can't listen to acquaintances
their opinions don't matter
okay you can't listen to the film how
you you can't wait I might feel like
that how do you work out
no go ahead I'm sorry I'm getting
excited you should talk go
sh
um basically like I I wanna because I I
follow you and I've been following you
for a couple years now and I do agree
what you have to say about education I
do think people are gonna start moving
from you know going to school and
sending their kids to school to finding
I've got you I've got your answer I've
got your answer a lot of people get up
you know what I'm gonna ask of course I
know I know exactly where you're going
so if you're not gonna get the PHD
there's only a few ways to justify and
gives confidence to the End Market
what what why they would jump with you
it's crazy to me that so many people I
was watching 60 Minutes last night in
the background as I was working and the
way that Oprah was justifying the person
was he has a PHD in this and a master's
in that even 60 Minutes use those pieces
of paper to create author Authority in
our society pieces of paper from
businesses and that's what colleges are
has been the authority the only other
people that get Authority are the people
that have gone out and done it and have
people co-signing them right makes sense
so the way and this is why I love
working for free when you don't have a
piece of paper right one of the reasons
I love working for free is working for
free for somebody who is that person in
society whether they got a piece of
paper or their Puff Daddy and they just
did it
becomes the equity that you trade under
once you become great at something right
Andy Andy who's sitting here right now
have every single famous person I see
gives him a lot of street cred right
away not because he got a degree for
personal branding and marketing for
Virginia Tech what degree did you get
political science not because of his
political science degree from Virginia
Tech but because he went and worked
underneath me and I went out and did it
and I always give him love and Good
Vibes the end
it's not Babin's degree from the USC
School of film or NYU
jumped out
you know so so what you need to do and
what you need to do is one of two moves
if you're not going to go get a PhD and
have everybody comfortable with it you
either need to go work for somebody that
is the authority and ask all thousands
of people that are authorities and work
for them or okay you need to give your
services for free to five couples crush
it for them and use their word of mouth
and endorsements and uh as your leverage
point the end technology and the way we
live doesn't care about my opinion or my
feelings and it doesn't care about yours
either and so you can walk around Earth
and judge oh it's so sad that all these
kids can't communicate because they're
on the phone anymore and you could talk
about a day and age when it was simpler
and nicer and all this nobody gives a
and if you don't adjust to the reality
of the situation you will be completely
left behind too many people are
executing or hoping or trying to figure
out how to live in a world that used to
be or the way they wish it was versus
attacking the reality of the world and
here is the reality of the world my
friends
the cell phones that you're all holding
right now or in your pocket are the
remote controls of our society they are
the single most important thing in the
world there's nothing close whatever you
want to happen in life you first need
somebody's attention and then you need
to tell them about it it was called the
newspaper the television and the radio
now it's called a Blog a vlog or a
podcast it's the same thing nothing's
changed except one thing your attention
is moving to a new place and leaving an
old place I'm making this very simple
very black and white very basic if you
do not spend next year completely
obsessing over how you become successful
on Facebook and Instagram you will be
disproportionately less likely to win
the ad product on those two platforms
are disproportionately underpriced
and that that is where you should be
trading you are grossly underestimating
what's happening right now
98 of people are grossly underestimating
how good it is right you will look back
at this talk all my content during this
era why am I producing so much content
during this era why am I flying around
the entire world over and over speaking
to this subject it's
know what I'm talking about right now
gonna go away
and I think we can all agree I'm not
hedging up here right now
I'm desperately trying to force this
down your mouth
right
you heard it
and I believe that 95 of you will not do
anything about it you'll do enough to
make it feel like you did something
and you will regret not going all in how
many people here play poker
good I don't but if you do
when you have the best hand it's a good
idea to go all in one theme that I
really people are like yo how do I build
my self-awareness how do I build my
optimism how do I change my mindset it's
the people around you if your best
friend is Debbie Downer you're not going
to be as optimistic as you can be if the
people that from your town that you hang
out with have no ambition you're going
absolutely nowhere if you listen to your
dad every day about how the government
sucks you're not gonna love life you've
got to audit Your Inner Circle podcast
friends listen to me listen very
carefully to this mashup and these
thoughts because this underlining tone
of who you surround yourself with
absolutely fundamentally changes who you
are period end of story when I hang out
with Silicon Valley in 2005 to 2010 I
was a different dude when I hang out in
the agency land right now I'm a
different dude when I'm like it's when I
was in college at Mount Ida different
dude like you're a different person and
I'm telling you right now this morning
podcast or this podcast because I know
some of you listen to it late this
podcast if I can get one of you one
person listening to this to dump one
loser person in their Circle and add one
whoever's that smiley happiest person at
work that you don't talk to that much
that's at the cubicle around the way or
that awesome like that you know how
everybody has like you have a friend but
their friend like went to college with
them you don't really know them but like
the three times you see them a year
they're positive and like they're doing
things surround yourself with those
people seek out your friend's friend who
brings Positive Vibes and make them part
of your world and cut out your homie
from college that thinks the world sucks
watch what that addition and subtraction
does to your life how are you what's
your name Alicia Alicia how you doing
good good okay so me my I want to become
um an author okay just like you amazing
and I have been
passion and I have I had applied to this
writing on YC team and I spilled my
heart out it was just me yes
they declined me yeah so it's like
it's like they yeah I get it it's like
that's me yeah it's like they're not
accepting me them but it's like she's
like you know honestly guys first of all
they didn't decline you one random
person that read your declined you them
but it's like imagine if I train some
stuff up if I change me they would have
probably took me you're wrong you're
wrong listen to my face I'm telling you
right to your face you're wrong you're
valuing somebody else's opinion too much
you're wrong
I I'm just telling you this is not this
is not a debate you're wrong do you
understand you're letting one random
person listen do you do you understand
how many people would have hired me none
Instagram in here
cool go to it right now please do
favor go to
answer garyvee that's my account go 10
11 Post back you'll see my report card I
was ranked 243rd out of 254 in my class
[Music]
243 out of 254 in my class you know why
because I knew it was [ __ ] for me it
might not be [ __ ] for you this is
about self-awareness you have to know
who the [ __ ] you are but for me it was
[ __ ] because I didn't need it
because I wasn't trying I didn't give a
[ __ ] with Saturn how many rings Saturn
had
listen to me you can't let something be
valuable more than you you're pandering
to them let them come to you take that
same essay and post that [ __ ] on
Instagram with a photo and see what
happens
see what happens let the market decide
not some [ __ ] middle management
person that read your [ __ ]
good
of course it's true and when you're
young and 13 and 15 and 9 you think you
got to change your [ __ ] up because you
don't know how it's played that's why
I'm here to tell you exactly how it's
played one person read your story my
dear and that person how do you balance
clouds in the dirt in which do you focus
on more and why so to find everybody how
I Define clouds and dirt clouds to me is
like the why the strategy the macro the
big thinking the big picture the
operating system of like how you do
things and then the dirt is having the
humility to go to these meetings to
actually I post on my Instagram photos
the doing the the humility ego humility
strategy execution clouds and dirt uh
the way I balance it is they're both
important at all times I can swing back
and forth to them I can literally go
from a meeting where like the call I had
on the way out to our first meeting here
today Purell was with vaynermedia's
c-suite about a restructuring of how we
handle all our business super meta and I
literally hung up and I posted something
on Instagram and wrote all the copy as
we were walking into our last meeting to
me I balanced them by doing whichever
one is needed at the time and so I don't
think about it as balancing it I think
about it as time allocation like what
should I be doing with my time and I
think that you know you made a joke of
like we did a shoot for a client that we
debated on the phone for 10 minutes
where the
should be located for that I think
that's being in the middle right I think
uh pandering to the way companies do
things we just had a meeting where
they're like oh that was provocative us
as
um as the gallery Media Group holds on
all the other things we do us doing what
every other publishing does company does
is not a good idea that's the middle
that's not going to get you to the next
place and so for me I'm just in the
mindset of you know do either doing
humble Dirty Work like the reason I am
the best strategist in social media
out there I really believe this is
because I do both I both sit at the top
of a media company that really does it
at scale for the biggest companies in
the world but at the same token there's
very few humans that put out a hundred
40 pieces of content by hand a week and
reads the con I mean I literally just
replied to Kyle in my comments who and
I'm going to show you because I don't
think you guys believe me when I do
these rants I literally just replied to
Kyle one second before Babin's like
let's do this video like literally what
I was doing one second before then was
replying to like literally like
literally hearted Kyle's comment of I'm
digging the recent pics and quotes man
right like
many many people watching here would
argue that my time at this point in my
career of reading Kyle's comment and
Harding it in that minute was a bad use
of my time I think the dirt
is the reason why I come up with such
good clouds being in the trenches drives
my strategy I live in reality and
practicality not in thesis or ideology
or reading headlines or reading about
people doing marketing uh so I don't I
don't balance it I just do whatever is
needed at that second
Mac you know it's back to macro micro
micro speed I'm just always doing
something
right Bobby like that is the big
breakthrough everybody on the team says
like there's just every second is and so
the reason I can do something every
second is and I don't watch a YouTube
video or stand by the water cooler and
talk about the Rockets game for 10
minutes is because I always value the
dirt and so in that half a second that I
had right now in the transition of the
call that I just had about a macro
Boehner X strategy
right the second transition I had before
I started doing a macro thing like the
Vlog
was Harding Kyle's two cents on my last
Instagram post clouds and dirt if you're
trying to reach the decision maker at a
retail organization that guy or gal is
also the same person that I want to
reach to sell a bottle of wine or a book
to and that space in his and her
Facebook feed is only one space
so that is supply and demand I used to
buy that space four years ago for a
dollar for every thousand Impressions
now it's seven the longer you think this
world doesn't exist and you fear
Margaret the longer you don't put money
in the longer I can extract all the
value I've lived this game I'm not a
hero because I took it from three to
fifty million 60 million my dad's
business I actually am a schmuck I
should have spent more on Google
I had it figured out every time you
typed in Cabernet Merlot Silver Oak
Camus Napa Bordeaux I was showing up
first because nobody realized it was
good real estate and it was only costing
me five or ten cents a click and I was
making between seven and eighty dollars
in profit for something that was costing
me three dollars to get you through the
funnel on the average of 60 people
coming and one converting I was stupid
I'm being serious with you I stand here
and have passion about LinkedIn and
Facebook marketing in a B2B environment
today out of regret for what I did from
2002 to 2005 because I should have spent
more it was basic math but I just didn't
understand
because I was young in my career and it
just I don't even know how to explain it
to you when it's too good to be true
it's too good to be true right I'm an
immigrant I was cynical I just didn't
plus I also thought it was important to
do direct mail and local commercials and
magazine I was doing it all but in
hindsight it was the great mistake of my
career
the great mistake of my career was not
spending more money on Google and I
promise you the great mistake of your
accelerated growth for the 80 that just
raised their hand is not taking
advertising on LinkedIn and Facebook
seriously because you don't think your
person is on it I've heard every guys
I've been doing this for 10 years I know
what your excuse is going to be I can't
wait to the Q a I'm going to stand here
and wanna but Gary my my target person
is a 63 year old man he's not on it
[ __ ]
of course he's on it who do you think is
spreading all the Democratic and
Republican propaganda on Facebook I was
born in Belarus in the former Soviet
Union I came to the U.S when I was three
we lived a very humble beginning as you
can imagine the economy wasn't super
great we didn't speak English we had a
hundred bucks uh I lived with seven
family members in a studio apartment in
Queens so it was super humble as you and
you know obviously my parents are very
much my heroes uh one because my mom is
the greatest parent of all time and two
because my dad worked his face off and
even though I slept under the same roof
literally every day of my life with my
dad in the first 14 years of my life I
literally never saw him because he left
at 7 A.M or 6 a.m and he came home at 10
p.m and he worked seven days a week
um how many people here are immigrants
or children of immigrants raise your
hands awesome so this group that just
raised their hands they know that
immigrants in America America have
absolutely figured out one of the core
Secrets which is you know work your face
off and don't buy dumb
and so that's kind of what my family did
for seven or eight years you know we my
dad wasn't making that much money but a
funny thing happens when you buy nothing
but food at the lowest possible price
and uh save save save save save save and
very quickly only six years after Coming
To America with 100 bucks my dad was
able to buy a small liquor store in New
Jersey we moved to New Jersey that is
where my entrepreneurial career began uh
when I was six I had a five Lemonade
Stand franchise
I uh manipulated my friends into
standing behind the lemonade all day and
that is when I became obsessed with
attention and this is really interesting
as you can see up here I day trade
attention culture and build businesses
at six years old
I would spend my summer days literally
walking up and down the streets of New
Jersey
sitting down on the curb watching cars
drive by so that I could figure out
which tree or post was better for me to
put a sign that said lemonade a quarter
that is DNA that's like somebody singing
That's like somebody throwing a pitch
really like that is just pure DNA I
didn't read a Seth Godin book or go to
Harvard Business School to figure out
that attention was the number one asset
the one thing that combines every person
here from the cameramen back there who
are producing to the industry that is in
this room to me to Mickey to anybody
else that sneaked in the one thing that
fundamentally connects all of us is
before you tell me how great your
product and services you need my
attention so that I listen I am obsessed
with attention I am obsessed with this
device because it has the attention I am
unemotional if it's ruining the kids and
they don't know how to engage or that
you were sad that people go out to
dinner and don't talk to each other
technology does not care about your
feelings
and so I as a human may have some
opinions about Parenthood and and
society and privacy as a human
but as a businessman I am unemotional
and not romantic all I do is follow
where the attention is and I figure out
how to storytell in there to create the
action that I desire I also think that
all of these things that we're talking
about can be scaled right so my career
is going along nicely and then and I'm
winning on email marketing 90 open rates
and I'm winning on Google AdWords the
day comes out I'm buying every wine term
that's working for my dad and then comes
along YouTube
and I see this platform and I say to
myself there's something here
and you can't run ads on it on the time
at the time
so
I decide to do a show
I never thought of myself this gift of
you know I thought of myself The Gift of
Gab but more like a good salesman or you
know a class clown that the teacher kind
of liked you know and so I
didn't realize what I was going to be
able to do in that format but I started
a very big show that garnered a lot of
attention and it really really worked
and it really got going and it really
taught me oh my God I don't have to
spend marketing money this attention is
trickling down organically
to my dad's business there's something
here and then Twitter came out and I
started using it to promote Wine Library
TV
and I'm like oh my God
this Friendster Myspace thing is about
to become much bigger this social it
wasn't called social media yet it was
called Web 2.0 Twitter was known as a
Web 2.0 app and
I started using it and Google buys
YouTube for 1.7 billion dollars and I
say to myself
oh my God I was right about this I was
right about Google AdWords I was right
about email I'm bet I'm not a wine
retailer I understand what people are
gonna do
I need to become an investor in what I
think people are going to do and 2007 I
invested in Facebook Twitter and Tumblr
and that obviously changed my life my
brother was graduating from college I
was starting to make videos about
business that were catching people's
attention and in 2009 I decided to start
vaynermedia to do marketing for the
biggest brands in the world so I could
learn big business because I understood
Silicon Valley I understood small
business entrepreneurship but I didn't
understand executive Fortune 500 land
and I didn't understand why they were
doing so many silly things in a world
where I thought Netflix Facebook
Amazon we're going to be the next big
thing and they turned out to be way
bigger than I even kind of predicted
even though I was predicting the tippy
top and so
that's been my career I've written five
New York Times best-selling books around
marketing and
um and consumer behavior and psychology
but what is all this hyperbole around me
mean it means that
I believe that every person who's
watching this right now is me in 2009.
here's what I mean by that I had a level
of success
I was good
I was enjoying myself I was building a
big company for my parents I was excited
to think about what I was going to do
for myself next
but the scale of the Internet by using
the tools completely changed my life
and I believe that what the internet
does is exposes things so I don't think
the internet changed me
I don't think it made me nicer and
stronger at my craft I think it made
more people aware that I was nice and
strong in my craft
and so I think for everybody who's
watching right now I don't think they
realize that if they started producing
content on LinkedIn about what they know
not what you think people want not to
get followers but to put out content of
what you know storytell my grandpappy
taught me when I was 10. this I now did
this for my sales person today that's
the video
you don't have to be an expert I'm not
an expert I'm a person that has
hypotheses and opinions and because a
lot of them became true after 15 years
and I've put the actual business wins on
the board now people look at me in a
different way
but I don't even you know even the
flattering introduction and our talk
beforehand
you know she makes me feel so good but I
don't think that makes me special I
think it's just a nice feeling to be
admired you know uh and and I think when
you later humility and curiosity around
being good at a tool great things happen
let me give you an example
when books came out yeah I'm being
serious now when books came out
clearly and I have no knowledge of this
but this is very easy to understand
clearly there were individuals who
became more aggressive at reading them
and amassed knowledge and my intuition
is the ones that were able to be
practical in operating were able to do
something with that knowledge and
succeed when tractors and Innovation hit
farming
the people that didn't demonize it and
many did many said that's not real
farming because they were fearful that
it was going to take away jobs from
their people which was a nice thing but
they were trying to fight technology
which is always the wrong answer let
there be no confusion if you hear or
feel anything from this keynote and Q a
today please let it be this if you were
fighting against technology you will
lose
it is the history of mankind I'm
secretly worried that I'm gonna get to a
place where I'm not going to care
anything about business and it's the
love of my life but I can like feel it
already I'm like
you know 55 to 75 is going to be some
run
when you actually believe in the value
you're providing
selling promoting
giving for free when you believe
it all clicks the reason people don't do
is because they don't believe they uh
either are insecure and structured that
way or they deep down know they're doing
it for the money
give me people like did things for me
with expectation
[Music]
because I don't even want to do that but
once in a while I say yes
mainly to stick it to them
and teach them A Life Lesson
which is don't come at me and be like I
want to do this awesome thing for you
and then kind of hover around and always
have this weird relationship with me
where they expect something like we did
something here like if you told me up
front that the reason you bought ten
thousand books and did this thing was
because what you really wanted was my
face on your website co-signing your
[ __ ] business well then you should
have told me
because then we could have had a
transaction a lot of your advice is
geared to like college grads yep but I'm
old I'm 40. what would you be like what
would your voice advice be for someone
who's 40 but starting out where most of
your audience is starting out when
they're 20 or 30. well it's interesting
no joke I don't know if you saw this I
literally posted a video today to 47
year olds I did not see that yet so uh
to me everybody's going through
different things you know I to your
point in the last eight 12 to 18 months
I found myself producing a lot more
content to youth than I have in the past
which was usually to more 40 year old
business people
um look I think the biggest thing with
40 to 50 is that it's now you've lived
life and you're still young as
and you're like now what right you have
like an entire second life to live and
it's a very interesting time in people's
lives where they have to be really
retrospective of like how self-aware are
they but honestly I think 40s young man
I really really do and so I would say a
lot of the advice I give to 20 year olds
Maps pretty well to 40 year olds which
is you know take some risks you've
tasted some stuff you know happiness is
the ROI and so you know figure out what
makes you happy is it the pursuit of
money or is it actual money do materials
make you happy if materials make you
happy is that really just insecurity and
you need to have you know a BMW to make
yourself feel good like what's making
you tick but I would say the biggest
thing that I would tell any 40 year old
is you've got 50 years to live please
get the I'm finished or I [ __ ] up like
eliminate dwelling because you're just
starting I really believe that by the
way this is not some motivational
rah-rah I just think it's true I just
think you've got 40 adult years to live
that's 20 more than you've lived there's
just so much Opportunity by the way this
whole notion of like you can do anything
and all this stuff let me just tell you
it's stupid hard
reality is most of you are just
averagely talented
right like you're not going to over
index anything too crazy here's the good
news this is not about how much money
you make or how talented you are this is
about being happy everybody here
regardless of how talented they are in
making money or art or what have you has
that they're super into you love Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles your whole life
could be about Michelangelo
it could and here's what really fits
with me in this internet age you could
have a podcast around Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles you could buy Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle memorabilia on
Craigslist and Facebook and Etsy and
then flip it on a different platform
because you're so knowledgeable because
that's the pizza eating Leonardo
that I'm just fascinated about what
happens when you go all in on your
passion you're committed to it and you
use the infrastructure of this you
living your life for 80 years as the
Teenage Ninja Turtle expert is getting
funnier to me by the second
making 83k a year in ads on your podcast
the flip some miraculous reason somebody
paid you two thousand dollars to go to a
bush League Comic-Con thing
hahaha
that person making 62 000 a year being
the TMT expert versus them making 77 000
a year being an admin in a company where
they hate their life nine to five that
Delta is something I will go to the
Grave on because it is what I want to
articulate to everybody the The
Unbelievable level of practicality to do
[ __ ] around stuff you like and here's
the big part
how many people under 40
let me just start with this group
if you just really took what I'm talking
about became an expert at Facebook and
Instagram really understood the fact
that you could take a leap for two years
move back in home move in together cut
your expenses I don't give a sh the fact
that you can do that for two or three
years and if it doesn't work out you can
go back
getting a job that's nuts
that's nuts
you've got to break out of that pattern
you gotta not listen to him and make
money in however way you want
listen otherwise you're stuck if you
want to help your mom sometimes the best
way to help your mom is to get out and
then come back and get her out online
I get it so honestly honestly and I
respect that listen to me life is long
you're in a spot right now my mom didn't
have her mom or dad
it sucks right now if when you're 14 it
feels like it's your life forever it's
not your light forever bro you
understand surround yourself with as
much positivity to get you through this
chapter
I have no friends
you've got to be patient it's early
forever
I get it but you have to understand
there's no alternative there's only two
choices here you stay under that roof
and each perform more years three more
years two more years or you bounce now
plenty of people bounce to 14. it's not
common in the UK but people do it or you
don't life's about a very simple option
either do it or don't if you're gonna
under that roof you need to put your
earpods in and listen to positivity 24
7. you understand when your surroundings
are your insides got to be positive the
fact that you're even here means you're
halfway home
listen
around you you have to make it positive
in your head I know it feels like it's
forever and it's gonna take forever when
you're 14 four more years sounds like
forever but you have no choice you
either bounce or you stay and if you
stay which is more likely which is fine
you gotta put positivity in your ears do
you understand I promise you you have no
other Alternatives otherwise you just
dwell and you go down a spiral that you
don't want to go down you understand if
you're self-aware you don't try to do
things you can't do
you focus on things you do like you
don't try to be something you're not if
you have self-esteem you're not scared
to put it out the content the video the
picture the audio
because you're not worried if Sally
pants 49 thinks you're ugly you're not
worried that Rick Thompson from a
competitive company says you're stupid
you're just not worried you're not
worried that you have bags under your
eyes or you're overweight or you're
losing your hair you're just not worried
you're you're focused on your
self-esteem you're focused on yourself
you're focused on your self-awareness
which puts you in a position to succeed
and so all of you one of the worst not
worst what are the challenging times in
my career was around 2012 when people
all wanted to be like me and I'm a very
very over the top high energy
personality who's very very comfortable
on video and that is just not going to
be the case for everybody and I tell
everybody and it took me a while to get
to this good answer which I think has
helped people listen my friends if
you're watching this right now and be
like okay I see what Gary's setting up
he's going to ask me to start producing
a lot more content that's the answer by
the way
well I don't want to do video well my
good news Sarah you don't have to do
video
you might for example I'm a terrible
writer if I was a great writer I'd be
writing a lot more because writing on
LinkedIn crushes as a matter of fact my
team loves when I I write all the copy
on my Instagram posts right all of them
everyone every post in my life and they
get pumped when I get motivated and like
write a real good one because we know
the post does better copy is the most
underrated thing in social media today
it drives so much of the success of the
picture in the video so by the way you
might be into audio you might be a
talker but you're insecure about your
visual of how you look or the camera
makes you freeze but you're great with
talking so good there's now Clubhouse an
incredible app you can go and be a
thought leader in there's just recording
audio and posting that on your LinkedIn
LinkedIn for this group knowing who's in
the room
is equivalent to what Facebook was in
2012.
that will lead to incredible financial
and emotional
success to those in here that heed the
call that I'm yelling today period end
of story I could not be more passionate
about everybody here getting very
serious and then what you put out
is up to you you know my recommendation
is that it brings value to people
whether it's entertaining whether it's
informational but I also believe that
stories stories are easier for people
this is something that I'm going to
start talking a lot about a lot more
about I think stories just stories like
life lessons grandma told me and then if
you're good at and I've already talked
brought this up I'm going to bring it up
again because I'm trying to help
everybody here give you some training
wheels if you say hi I'm Karen I'm a
sales lead at this company I this is for
my team but honestly this is from a
broader world because all you sales
leaders I know how it is
you know when I was nine my grandmother
took me to a girl scouts event and Sarah
Johnson did this and my grandma I did
this and grandma told me to do that and
then I did this and me and Sarah Johnson
were best friends in high school and
that's ironic because I had a big Tiff
between Carl and Carla recently on my
team and I did this like my grandma did
that and now they just closed the
biggest account together that story that
should come very natural and by the way
you don't need to call out Carl and
Carla right because that's active you're
in the world right now you could be two
people on my team just think about how
easy that is for what everyone's
struggling with which is well what do I
post
what do I post is grounded in lack of
self-esteem and lack of strategy
period
and so
I'm here today to build your self-esteem
and not in a delusional way I'm just
trying to encourage you to realize how
real this is because the content
creators that build awareness and
audiences will have the leverage in
business whether it's a small narrow
world and by the way this is a small
narrow sector most of the business
people on this call in this thing that's
great actually
the reality is that's great because then
you run a couple dollars in ads on
LinkedIn against targets of companies
that are in your sector and you're
getting exactly who you want I actually
like when groups are narrow because you
can get so much more specific
so anyway I'm just very excited to be
here I want to encourage
everyone to realize the opportunity Evan
thank you so much for having a couple
seconds and being able to tell the
believe Nation a little bit about
empathy wines it means a lot to me that
you would take this valuable real estate
and and time on your channel to give me
some love means a lot it's just good
karma points and so you're just you're
awesome thank you believe Nation uh if
you're into wine at all go to
empathywines.com my whole careers work
was poured into producing a wine that
rivaled 40 to 60 dollar wine for 20
bucks a bottle uh I'm just super excited
about this subscription-based wine
business you can order three six or 12
bottles in subscription form Rose white
red
um if you if you search on Instagram or
Twitter you will be blown away people
are literally like I don't even like
garyvee but the line's good super proud
of the effort thanks Evan for the time
uh wishing you guys all happy and
healthy
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the last one on one I did
with Gary vaynerchuk check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there I'm talking about something
that the world thinks is a contradiction
I don't understand why anybody should
ever verbally dress down an employee